[Music]
our world one hero will have to learn to
control his powers okay Sonic you got
the super speed and you gotta learn how
to control it try these on all right
looking good this year this is my power
any last words is that all you've got no
but thank you for asking
you've got car insurance
Sonic the Hedgehog here's Tom's best
friend I don't see the appeal
[Music]
so get ready here we go that was an
illegal left by the way for the crazy
bastard let me show you how it's done so
should we get out of here yeah time to
go
incredibly fearless any last words be
strong be strong and move to ruin I
can't with that guy adventurer of the
year the Hedgehog what am i good time
this is the island where I'm from it had
everything sandy beaches test gating
waterfalls public access to
loop-de-loops and I never had to catch a
school bus because I could run across
the entire island in less than two
seconds also there was no school I know
pretty sweet Island right
best friends come in all shapes and
sizes who are you
what for you I'm a hedgehog I feel like
that's obvious this year the entire
military is after me I need your help
right come with me
stay in there gonna be quiet do you have
your child in that bag yes it's a child
but it's not my I'm heading home
hold on you got card Church right Sonic
the Hedgehog you didn't hit hey I got us
here and please five stars
I'm Sonic I'm here to protect my friends
the government wants to dissect you and
arrest me we gotta lay low let me show
you how it's done
that was an illegal
are you not dead I have no idea
Sonic the Hedgehog okay my name mayhem
that's not good looks like I'm gonna
have to save your planet you'll never
catch me
oh boy how are you not dead I have no
idea
Sonic the Hedgehog this year who are you
I'm Sonic I'm actually here to save your
planet you've got car insurance right
he's super fast good times these super
charming you're Tom's best friend I
don't see the appeal the peace
supersonic
so should we get out of here yeah time
to go Sonic the Hedgehog I'm okay with
this power no one can stop me
[Music]
howdy partner this book missing a head
or does it have two buttons
we only have one chance to stop it we're
running out of time what am i doing
that was an illegal left by the way
oh you're not dead I have no idea of
some of the hedgehog I'm Sonic a little
ball of super energy in an extremely
handsome package on my planet people
were always after my powers so I came to
yours it gets a little lonely I can't
with that guy are you hiding out in my
garage they steal my power did you
conquer the universe
you have to help me Louie don't please
it's life or death good morning my royal
chum mr. dr. Robotnik I'm going to give
you five seconds to tell me where it is
wait don't hurt him
Rhodri this can't be happening me oh my
god stop back alright what the world's
largest rubber band bulb we gotta see it
no this is not some fun family road trip
Yeah right
it was lame gift shop was cool though
whatever this creature is I'm going to
uncover the source its power
[Music]
I just thought you might like a latte
with steamed Austrian goat milk of
course I would a lot of take I love the
way you make them you gotta lay low let
me show you how it's done so should we
get out of here yeah it's time to go I
always want to do this
I have no idea that was a legal left by
the way why would you throw the life
away for this silly little alien good
time is my friend let's go
[Applause]
my power
and I'm using it to protect my four
so you're supposed to be Tom's best
friend that he won't shut up about well
I don't see the appeal
[Music]
[Music]